decenas de miles de personas se
reunieron en la capital de la Biblia
este sábado para protestar contra el
gobierno de Benjamin netaniau es la
quinta semana de protestas contra los
planes de reformas del Primer Ministro
los manifestantes denuncian que se trata
de un intento de concentrar los poderes
estoy aquí porque es una protesta
importante contra Un gobierno corrupto y
un Primer Ministro corrupto que quiere
destrozar el sistema judicial de Israel
quieren destrozar la democracia israelí
y estamos aquí cada semana en cada
momento para luchar contra ello y para
luchar por la democracia israelí
desde su regreso al poder en diciembre
Benjamin netaniau y su gobierno han
anunciado varios proyectos de reformas
judiciales controvertidas entre ellas
una que permitiría al parlamento anular
decisiones del tribunal supremo con una
mayoría simple y otra que permitiría a
la coalición del primer registro nominar
más magistrados y obtener una mayoría en
la Corte Suprema algo que jugaría a
favor del Primer Ministro que está
siendo procesado por tres casos de
corrupción distintos ya que si es
condenado podría apelar la decisión ante
esa corte algunas reformas sociales
también preocupan de la comunidad
lgbtqimas como familia queer este
gobierno intentará aprobar leyes que
afectarán a mis hijos por eso se sienten
muy preocupados y nos hacen muchas
preguntas
el partido de Benjamín
ganó la mayoría en las elecciones
legislativas a finales del año pasado al
formar una coalición con partidos Ultra
ortodoxos y de extrema derecha metan
Yahoo volvió a ser Primer Ministro tras
haber ocupado este puesto durante más de
15 años